[Music]
i grew up a movie kid my parents had the
local theater in town so my sisters and
i spent a tremendous amount of time in
the theater i spent a lot of time in the
game room and in the arcade playing
games but also i really developed an
appreciation for what cinema was
and really it's much more than a picture
on screen it's an escape and i really
developed an appreciation for that
seeing so many people coming through the
theater
i just thought it would be great to
create kind of a one-stop shop
entertainment experience for everyone
that way they didn't have to go to
different places and they could go to a
single spot and then choose their
journey from there
i'm mitch roberts i'm the founder and
ceo of evo entertainment group we
combine all the different elements of
out of home entertainment so it's one
single venue that encompasses bowling
video games restaurant bar anchored by
the cinema
[Music]
i started in 2014 i was 18 at the time
and i didn't really know
what i was getting myself into i know
the movie business i didn't know much
other than that and so over
time
i think the biggest component of it all
is
surrounding myself with intelligent
talented people
that can teach me the things that i
don't know but also make the impact and
make the experience that much better in
ways that i couldn't do on my own
i didn't want to go bring on a bunch of
traditional cinema guys because that's
not the only thing we were doing
i wanted people from all aspects of
hospitality entertainment anything that
was attendance driven or experience
based one thing that my grandfather
always taught me was if you're the
smartest person in the room you're in
the wrong room
[Music]
the early days were a lot of fun it was
being on the ground working in the
venues all the time talking to people
what they liked about the venues what
they didn't like about the venues so we
would take all that feedback and then
adjust so as you you visit our different
venues you see little changes along the
way you know there's no two venues that
are exactly alike and the reason for
that is
just being so involved and being a small
company that you can make those changes
i think as we've gotten larger
particularly in the last six months as
the growth has really picked up we've
had to get a little bit more streamlined
and focus on the efficiencies in the
business aspect of it a little bit more
than the creative side
but we're still heavily focused on the
creative side of it just because that
was the root of who we were in the
beginning now we just have to be a
little bit more
grown up if you will
we were coming off of two record years
in 2018 and 2019 consecutive record
years so we were feeling really good
going into 2020 and then of course the
pandemic hit which was a dramatic event
for restaurants bars cinemas all the
things that we do one thing that covid
did is it highlighted your weaknesses or
the places that you could get better so
we had to make a really quick pivot
there
we did that in a number of ways from
turning our parking lots into drive-in
theaters we pivoted to food delivery
from a mobile app
we made like pumpkin patches for
halloween we made a paintball course so
it's just this whole
culture that we built
of never giving up and constantly
pivoting and adapting to the challenges
we're faced with we're constantly
looking at ways to improve or different
things that we can do and that's what
led us to where we are today
[Music]
showbiz was our largest deal to date
they were a what we call a multitainment
brand where they they have cinema and
bowling as well and so when we're able
to complete that acquisition what it did
is it tripled the size of our company
now we're in 16 venues we have 148
screens across texas oklahoma florida
and wyoming so it was a tremendous
change and tremendous step forward for
our business and positions us as the
largest operator of the cinema
entertainment center concept in north
america
in five to ten years i hope that we're a
national brand first of all but also i
think that our concept if done right and
continues to go the way it's going can
be a positive change for cinema in
general people have prophesized the fall
of cinema for a hundred years it's every
advancement in technology every downturn
in the economy people say that it's
going to be the downfall of cinema but
it's never died i think if you provide
an experience a good quality experience
there will always be demand for that
there will always be demand for shared
experiences and shared emotions and
watching a story unfold on screen
it's just we have to consistently adapt
and improve and evolve the way that we
show those films on screen
similar to retail people say retail's
dead retail is not dead
bad retail is dead
movie theaters are not dead they're not
dying
bad movie theaters are dead or down
you